hello everyone and welcome to uh day
three of this year's Super United rapid
tournament in Croatia it is even charity
versus yanipunashi and these are the
standings after the two rounds of Rapid
there you have it Fabiano Corona
yanipanushi and vishwanathan are leading
the tournament with eight points
followed by Young Shish to do dangukash
with seven with six points Magnus
Crossing and Rehab Rapport alares
and Constantin lupuscu in last place as
uh I was planning on showing another
game from round six I didn't get to it
so that's why I'm showing you the
standings now so you know what we are
dealing with as it is very important for
what happens next so now uh nepo is on a
very good streak he won all of three
games uh in the second day of the rapid
he won the game four game five in game
six and now he faces even charge even
has the white pieces and he's one of the
most unpleasant players you could meet
um uh when when wielding the white
pieces so let's see what happens here
it's a grueling Battle of Chess Theory
first 19 moves are are just Theory so
we're just gonna fly through them and
then basically it unfolds over the
course of maybe three moves so let's
check it out even has the white pieces
and he opens with E4 as he usually does
with C5 by nepo Knight to a three
Knights the D6 upon the D6 and now I
mentioned in the previous couple of
videos that everyone plays either the
all up in C3 or the bishop to B5 check
variation uh and very rarely do we see
D4 nowadays but as even is a sicilian
player himself he loves sharp uh play uh
he goes for D4 so C Captain D4 we have
the main line of the Sicilian Knight F6
Knight the C3 and Ponte A6 it doesn't
get any better than this the Knight of
variation of the Sicilian is on the
board we have Bishop D3 the English
short or the burn attack with a pawn to
E5 and Knight to B3 Bishop to E7 and now
Pawn to F3 as strengthening the D for
pawn bishop to E6 and now Queen to D2
preparing the castle Queen side nipple
castles King side even even Castle's
Queen side and now Knight beat the D7
the Knight is coming to C5 then B5 B4 uh
you you know the moves uh we have
castles on opposite sides of the board
so obviously it's going to be a race and
whoever gets the attack first usually
wins the game so G4 we have found the B5
and G5 all been played before nothing
new Here pawn to B4 attacking the Knight
and bound uh White has many good choices
here off of which all of them have been
played in id2 the most popular you could
go Knight to D5 you could go a night's
day four you could capture on F6 this
actually what nepo goes for uh we have B
counters and C3 Queen characters and now
you don't have time for Rook to see it
because captors and E7 would be
attacking the queen so first you need to
capture back and now Knights the A5 now
you want to play Knights the C6 attack
the queen and the bishop uh take off the
dark Square Bishop from the board and
enjoy the rest of the game having a
bishop pair while your opponent doesn't
so well Rook the C8 is the common move
here nepo tries to guess trick shortage
into something because Queen T8 has only
been played like two times but uh even
will not be tricked he just continues
with Knight to C6 and would Rook to see
it we transpose into the very uh known
line that everyone plays Knight captures
an E7 check Wing captures and now Queen
day five again all been played before
Rook the C6 defending the pawns here and
preparing to double up on the C file as
the C2 Pawn is somewhat weak and there
are a couple of moves that reach this uh
moves that were played in this position
Rock the G1 is a normal just a nice
prophylactic King the B1 is a normal as
you know those Rooks are coming to the C
file also Rook the D2 has been placed I
help out with the support of the c21
also to double up on the G file uh some
Bishop D2 moves have been played but
here uh nipple goes uh sorry even goes
for Ponte H4 and it is now as of move 19
that we have a completely new game so
this is basically where our game starts
like in the olden days you know in the
old shata range where you had the uh the
mansubas which were the positions that
you know there were like 500 of them uh
and uh you know they just started every
game after 50 moves because all of the
variations were known uh prior to that
but they were simpler rules of course
um in chess we are far from that but you
know some uh a thousand years into the
future we could actually have that with
chess as well who knows uh but okay
after Pawn to H4 that we have Rook after
C8 of course doubling up on the C file
going after the uh C2 pawn and now Rook
the H2 defending the C2 Pawn with Ponte
H6 and now Pawn to B3 and here already
uh you will see some problems for even
with this weakening of the position uh
now you want to play King to B1 or
always you want to play this and then D5
will not be as potent however after this
B3 move nipples D5 is incredibly potent
as the A3 square has been weakened so
here Pawn to D5 and now how do you react
to this uh it's uh well it's it's very
tricky because after pulling captures
you will play Knight captures on D5 and
now also the C3 square has been weakened
and once the Knight comes to C3 you know
it's just gonna remain there for the
rest of the game
so instead after D5 King the B1 even
sacrifices upon although it's not uh not
really the the best sacrifice uh point
is that if now F captures an E4 Knights
to G4 just completely cripples uh white
as you're attacking the bishop the rook
and also okay The Rook can defend the
bishop but after you trade here also the
C2 Pawn Falls this is a game over so
instead after d counters any four even
captures the E5 pawn and now just e
captures an F3 uh we end the variation
with Nepal being up upon and it's a fast
Pawn already on F3 we have Bishop to D4
now if the Knight moves okay maybe you
get a Checkmate here but now Queen to D6
nipples is my position is better I want
to trade down into a winning end game
and enjoy my pass Pawn already and F3 so
Rook H to D2 and nepo just trades Queens
with countress captures and now Bishop
to F5 putting even more pressure on that
C2 Pawn so Bishop to C4 stopping the
Rooks from reaching the C2 Pawn but now
Knight sorry Knights the if for
attacking The Rook also threatening a
knight to C3 check which will ruin the
Rook on D1 and here you already feel
that really there are no moves you have
to go for Rook 38 to check as you will
be losing the exchange at least Rook
captures Rook captures with check King
the H7 and now Bishop to F1 you cannot
allow uh any Rook captures on C4 moves
because then the pawn will just be
unstoppable with F6 attacks the bishop
Bishop to B8 and now Pawn to G5 the
bishop here will be used to somewhat to
counter those past pawns but yeah as
you'll see it's not going to be enough
uh sorry about that we have King the B2
Now by Evan and we have G captures and
H4 and this is a beautiful moment in the
game because there are two kinds of
players there are those that will play
G4 and I consider myself one of those
people I mean you you play G4 you play
G3 you play G2 and that's this game over
there's no reason to mess up your Pawn
structure uh just for the purpose of
capturing a pawn and the engine really
the engine says like this is winning
this is winning the engine doesn't
prefer one or the other but nipple as he
is I mean there are taught like that in
in the Russian School of chess if you
can grab a pawn you always grab a pawn
and nepo grabs it I mean he doubles now
both of his pawns but the H3 square is
covered he's gonna uh he's gonna win
this game but it just looks like why
would you do this to yourself you just
play G4 and the pawns are unstoppable
but okay that's why he was a World Chess
Championship Challenger and I most
certainly am not so G captures on H4 we
have Bishop to D3 and now Pawn to F2
just advancing that pawn Rook the E8 and
now Knights to D6 attacking the rook and
E8 Rook D7 check King to G6 and he was
in this position on move 35 that even
charge resigned in the game as there is
nothing more to be done here nepo gets
his fourth win in a row and he takes the
lead in the tournament uh some of the
other games are still being played while
I'm recording this so I don't know the
exact standings I can check if they were
finished while I was recording so let me
just quickly check
uh there we go so currently we have okay
so both Fabi and nipple on 10 10 out of
14 uh Fabi also uh won his game very
nicely against Google cash uh and Anand
in third place with nine points so very
nicely done we'll see what happens two
more rounds uh in the Rapids uh we'll
see if nepophobi or Anand will take it
all the ways and has been leading the
entire tournament then he had that slip
against Magnus he just has a I mean a
sort of a mental blockade against Magnus
but who wouldn't he defeated you in a
World Chess Championship Match twice uh
obviously that will you know leave a
mark uh but okay what are you gonna do
here you resign because uh well uh
simply once the bishop leaves the board
you cannot stop onto F1 so you can
prolong it a little bit like let's say
Pawn to F1 but now Rook captures and C
to check King A3 Knight to B5 checking
whatever doesn't really matter you're
gonna play Rook to C1 attack the bishop
and uh well now Bishop G2 to still sort
of guard DF to one square but now I mean
even even just this is winning but also
you can just play Knight D4 Bishop to A7
sort of trying to win that pawn but now
F1 Queen and after Bishop captures even
Knights the C6 check with a beautiful
Fork here forking everything white has
left because the bishop will be captured
by The Rook uh and that's it so once you
move it like Rook captures on F1 Now The
Rook Rook is saying Bishop is hanging
yeah you resign here uh nothing uh
nothing to be played here as well of
course uh knew that and that's why he
resigned after an apple played King to
G6 uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it like I said nepo and
Fabi in the lead uh on trailing by only
a point we'll see what happens in the
two remaining rounds of the super super
United rapid tournament in Croatia I
would like to thank James Eugene Cashman
John Austin not complies Paul Miller and
Brad Roth for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
yeah always be careful when you prepare
a novelty you have to also know how to
play it and not just have it prepared
see you soon